Gary's telling me that somehow I don't
know how he got into this but he's
having a vinyl party at Rachael Ray's
house
well she said he keeps threatening Gary
what's up are you gonna do that now
are you personal friends oh I'm friends
with with their executive producer and
also a little friendly with her husband
so I invited the executive producer do
you know I said we're gonna try to put
something together so we're you're gonna
do it I said we haven't figured it out
yet but he called me back a couple days
later he said they'd like to host it so
what is a vinyl party again for those of
us who don't so it'll just be a bunch of
people who like vinyl and then bring and
everyone will bring a record and then we
have a theme of the pool have a theme
for the party which has a bit chosen yet
jukebox songs
[Laughter]
my Frank Sinatra have you ever been over
Rachael Ray's apartment but why do you
need to sit in a room with Fred Armisen
enjoy more like a community experience
than a listening experience it's not
like we're going for four high fidelity
you talk while the music is going
there's a crackle coming up what do you
what kind of theme you're thinking about
it Rachel says how about Desert Island
Discs what do you mean a cooking a food
thing like the fellated song food yeah
like love rain Oh me what would be a
food song yummy yummy yummy I got love
in my tummy
would that qualify yeah I guess that
would American Pie bars down on the
cleaners did when is the last time you
went to a vinyl party and what was it
where was the theme it might have been
one where cities didn't you bring Chuck
Berry the b-side Habana moon that's
correct
[Music]
something even Chuck Berry doesn't want
to hear Chuck Berry was embarrassed by
that
[Laughter]
the lousiest will be there I think like
John Hein is joining me and there's a
couple people work on the staff that
would like to go where to Rachel Ray's
apartment damn right I like to see
what's doing we're gonna play the entire
breakfast in America by Supertramp
because it's a scene how about these
people that were in before they knew
where it was going to be how about hey
good-looking well you got cooking up
with me yeah jambalaya jump about Hank
Williams yeah that's food for more on
this topic let's go to our phone Robin
Gary audio book is on ah hi Gary how you
doing this is Gary yeah what's up I love
being that guy when it comes to music
knowledge right here here I used all the
money I earned mowing lawns and
delivering newspapers to buy records I
even used my mowing money to buy rock
and roll trivia books a plastic sleeves
for all my album what is it all my 45s
on a shelf in my room right next to my
bed in alphabetical order what is it
about alphabetizing albums and and being
that guy and what is that guy yeah right
here all right thanks he likes being I
don't know what that guy is before the
internet people would often call me for
to ask questions about music That's Gary
puppet are you that guy I'm that guy
right lady momologue voulez-vous coucher
avec moi ce soir
real Gary does everyone high-five when a
really cool song comes on or no
everybody is talking right and then what
if somebody's the next person's turn out
green man's coming on shake your little
spiel about why they picked the song
another song plays and then everybody's
continues to drink and talk and then the
next person comes out all right the
listening is all right I'm gonna kill
myself
all right thanks Jerry